it isn't worth noting
that the personality determined malaise
of groupthink produces once again those
four most frequently occurring symptoms
of past military incompetence
wastage of manpower
overconfidence
underestimation of the enemy
and ignoring of intelligence reports
these
it seems
are the enduring hazards
of professionalizing violence
and i can tell you these are not only
the hazards of professionalizing
violence these are the enduring hazards
for us as human beings as leaders
that we can all fall into
and as you pointed out this book is a
is a big warning of what not to do
i i gotta i said it was the last thing
i'm gonna read but there's a look this
guy's funny and i did a bad job of
relaying some of his humor here's the
afterward
of this book and this is the last thing
i'm going to read from this book after
six podcasts
sure he says
this is so british he says lest the
reader should have doubted my
qualifications to write this book let me
assure him that i have marked
authoritarian traits
a weak ego
fear of failure motivation
and no illusions about the fact that i
would have made a grossly incompetent
general
it takes one to no one
that was from the author in 1975. it's a
little bit of humor and you know he says
it takes one to no one
but that's unfortunately not true
it's unfortunately not true
if you think you're incompetent
there's a better chance that you're not
incompetent
you can see where i'm going this if you
think you're incompetent there's a
there's a better chance that you're not
incompetent because if you think you're
incompetent you're you're actually
humble and you're thinking oh you know i
don't
man i need to listen to what other
people have to say
i need to check myself i need to learn i
need to open my mind and see what other
information i can gather because i
gather because i feel like i might be
incompetent
so if you feel kind of when people ask
me about the imposter syndrome yeah what
about imposters good
that means you're actually thinking man
do i even need to be i always had that i
always felt like oh man if i'm gonna
need to be making decisions i better do
my homework
i better think this through i better pay
attention
so if you think you're incompetent you
probably aren't
but if you've been listening to these
six straight podcasts and you've been
thinking that this book is about all the
uncompetent leaders around you that's a
little warning sign be careful because
if you are in that mindset where you
think
man i can't believe how jacked up all
these other leaders are well not you
red flag
because chances are
this is about you
and look here's the other red flag it's
a scale right you brought that up it's
it's a it's a continuum yeah
and so we all of us
even if you feel like you're pretty
competent you are
under threat of being dragged to
incompetency so all these little this
book is just a warning sign after a
warning sign after warning sign and by
the way there's nothing new there's
almost nothing new there's one thing
that i said that's a new thought to me i
forget what it was
but in these 400 pages and whatever we
just did 12 15 hours worth of podcasts
it's all a it's a rehash it's a
reinforcement of information that i
already knew that we already knew that
we talk about all the time that we've
seen in a bunch of other situations
it's a rehash
but
we're all
getting
you can we can all get pulled
over there we can get pulled towards
that authoritarian mindset because you
know why we get pulled towards the
authoritarian mindset we get pulled
towards that authority mindset because
it seems easier
it seems easier to say shut up and do
what i told you to do it seems easier to
say you know what i'm not going to
listen to that piece of information
it seems easier to do that it seems like
the right move
it seems easier to say you know what the
competitor's never going to be able to
do what we're doing
it seems easier and it's not
so you got to get watched you got to
watch out you got to pay attention
you're going to be careful we all have
to be on guard incompetence incompetence
is out there sort of ready to attack
it's ready to attack yes sir and if
you're not on guard it'll grab you it'll
pull you down and you'll be making bad
decisions and getting people killed or
ruining your business or ruining your
marriage or ruining your life
through incompetence so
we have to pay attention
you got to be careful uh we got to stay
on the path yes sir
the path
speaking of which you know yeah what do
you got for us how do you advise we we
we avoid incompetence
mental incompetence leadership
incompetence physical incompetence well
yeah we don't want to have that what do
you got for us echo that was the uh what
do you call the dunning-kruger effect
right that you kind of referred to where
the the it takes one to know and that's
not necessarily true
yeah that it
feels like when you
you think you know everything it's like
it's easy to know everything when you
think there's only like three or four
things to know
but then when you start jujitsu and
you're like man once i know how to stop
that arm lock i'll be good kind of be it
yeah because you got arm locked three
times yeah by some random you know blue
belt and you're like oh dude i'm gonna
stop that and then you get chilled
figured it out did you learn how to stop
the joke then your heel hooked yeah it
did not stop that heel hook yeah it just
goes on yeah stop yeah so the guy well
actually it does stop after like you get
heel hooked arm locked ezekiel choked
freaking then you go oh there's a lot
more i don't know what i'm doing yes so
it takes a minute to convince you of
that yeah so that's when you kind of
when the
it's all the dunning-kruger effect it's
it's essentially like yeah when you
think you people who are like so
confident they're the ones that know
less than the people who are like not
confident at all because they know how
much there is not to know almo you know
they have a grasp on it or whatever yeah
dave good deal dave said something i
forget his exact words but i wish i
remembered it was something like oh yeah
there when he's talking about jiu jitsu
he was like um yeah it's it's almost
like you get what you you learn what do
you say it's almost like you get worse
over time because yesterday there was
only three things i didn't know like now
there's like 40 things that i don't know
kind of tomorrow there's a thousand
years yeah yeah the day that you start
to look start to feel okay is when you
go oh there's an infinite number of
things i don't know yeah yeah i just
don't know anything yeah i think exactly
right